but tragically George Floyd's name joins
an ever-growing list of black men whose
killings were supposed to usher in a new
era of racial equality in America
especially eight years ago that name was
Trayvon Martin a 17 year old from
Florida shot as he walked home and whose
death became a focal point for anti
racism campaigners across the United
States Trayvon's mother Sybrina Fulton
joins us live now from Miami welcome to
you it's hard to believe that it's
already eight years since Trayvon's
killing how are you I'm doing well I can
actually say I'm doing fairly well how
did you feel when you you saw those
images that have been played out across
our screens of George Floyd being killed
it's heartbreaking it's disgusting to
know that we're still being treated like
animals like what three-fifths human and
it was awful it was awful to hear George
seeing what happened to him such
disrespect and to know that he was
calling out for his mom who was already
in heaven and what sort of memories did
it bring back for you oh it brought
memories back of my son in the tragic
you know death that he had and just to
know there's so many people are
supporting George Floyd and you know I
stand with him as well I stand with his
family as well just so I can do my part
to you know just make sure that my voice
is heard I definitely feel like change
is gonna come that was one of the things
that I heard in the clip that you just
played most definitely change is going
to come but we have to keep the pressure
on and we to make sure that we have laws
in place and make sure that we make the
necessary changes some people don't
continue to treat us a certain way and
talking about keeping that that pressure
on a year after Trayvon was killed the
black lives matter movement would was
set up it and you've started the Trayvon
Martin foundation do you think that
group action makes a
friends I absolutely do I absolutely
think that united we stand I absolutely
think that you know the voice of so many
different people from all walks of life
it doesn't matter if you're poor middle
class or rich if you're educated or
uneducated it doesn't matter if you're a
Christian Baptist Muslim a Jewish it
doesn't matter those things it doesn't
matter if you're straight or gay those
things are not are important what's
important is that these are human beings
that we all are human beings and we
shouldn't treat each other
accordingly we should treat each other
and respect each other no matter what
your religion is no matter what the call
of your skin is as we know that the
debate around criminal justice continues
today we've had Donald Trump the
President of the United States signing
an executive order restricting police
use of chokehold do you welcome that has
that gone far enough for you instead
unless it was necessary or they fear for
their life if you know we have had
people being shot in the back and I
don't understand you know some of the
things some of that language that law
enforcement uses and you know some of
the language that even a president used
today you know it could be questionable
but I just think that people need to
stop killing us for no reason if it
would ever George Floyd did he should
have been arrested for it and not it
should not have cost in his life you
attended that the funeral of a George
Floyd obviously you witnessed that the
grief the loss and and the anger do you
think that his killing is a tipping
point is something different this time
the difference I see now is a lot of
young people are involved in their
surplus a lot of people from all walks
of life and involved in it was recorded
on video so the narrative would have
been a little differently had we not had
a video we would have heard that that
George Floyd resisted arrest so that he
was belligerent or something like that
and in the office of fear for his life
but that's not what we saw because of
the video we were able to see and he was
handcuffed he was on the ground
his face was pressing the ground he was
calling out that he couldn't breathe he
was calling out for his mother while he
was being restrained by three officers
and the fourth officer was standing
there and so all people all parties
involved need to be held accountable
regardless whenever there's a loss of
life they need to be held accountable
Sybrina Fulton thank you very much for
speaking to us this evening